hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
Monster Hunter world is being released
far sooner than I expected
during the Tokyo Game Show capcom have
revealed five details about the game
which if you're looking forward to this
action RPG like me will whet your
appetites and if you're still on the
fence about this one the gameplay and
new enemies shown may help you make your
decisions we've also made a video
outlining the game's mechanics so our
link that should the game look
interesting to you let's start with the
release date January 26 2018 yes indeed
it's in touching distance not only that
we now know so much more about monster
hunter world and the new enemies will be
facing in previous demos we've seen many
reptilian and dinosaur x monsters but in
the latest story trailer we see some
mind-blowing sights if like me you're a
newcomer to the series or you haven't
played for many years we will get to
know the names of each of the beasts in
due course what naturally springs to
mind are the elements of different
species you can spot whether it's a
feathered serpent squirrel thing or an
albino bat who needs a good shearing the
attention to detail is astonishing
because these monsters are so varied
tactically we will be challenged facing
these as each encounter will require a
different approach
although the story has not been fleshed
out massively we have seen snippets of
our character finding the home base of
astera and the elements and individuals
will be interacting with such as other
hunters the blacksmiths scholars and or
even the cooks and the chefs oh my word
the food looks so delicious in this game
that doesn't make you saying I don't
know what will remain we also get to
meet the military leader of the
commission as we prepare to fight the
flagship beast of monster hunter world
no gig ante no Gigante have no idea
that's right all right
[Music]
the optin world will be completely
seamless meaning we can drop into the
story or continue the grind of hunting
our prey and upgrading our character
before once again returning to the story
without leaving the experience I cannot
wait to see that in action
[Music]
also unveiled at Tokyo Game Show are the
pre-order bonuses created to get you
hooked early on the Digital Deluxe
Edition comes with a host of digital
goodies which are also said to be
available with the disc copies if you're
like me and prefer a physical item to
cherish alongside a fair wind charm and
an origin set of armor are further
goodies a full set of samurai armor will
be downloadable alongside three emotes
or gestures if you prefer Zen ninja star
and sumo slap we haven't seen all these
in action yet but the Zen pose seems to
be a kneeling moment of tranquillity any
ideas what ninja star and sumo slap
could be I have visions of a Honda here
other digital goodies include PSN
avatars and stickers too but it's the
last item that has piqued my interest a
new hairstyle and face paint hopefully
this indicates we really can stand out
from the crowd with unique character
builds unlocking cosmetic items can be
so addictive and fingers crossed they
have a 3-foot beard and Mohawk
combination to unlock if you're a big
monster hunter fan the collector's
edition may be something to consider
with all the above items plus a
soundtrack an art book and a figurine
for your man cave or whatever the female
version of a man cave is a lady lady
cave that does not sound right quickly
moving on there's even a monster hunter
world limited edition ps4 if that floats
your boat so January 2018 cannot come
quick enough for me I'm looking to be
completely invested in monster hunter
world but what about you are you new to
the series or a veteran
I'd love to know your thoughts on
monster hunter world by the way I'll be
getting my first hands-on with monster
hunter world this week so I'll feedback
my thoughts very soon I imagine from
Playstation grenades it's been a
pleasure I'll see you next time
[Music]
you